hallo herzlich willkommen manuel
weiter ist ein ganz besonderer tag
murat hat endlich ein mikrofon ich weiß
auch nicht ob ich mich freuen oder auf
beiden sollen
ich glaube die leute freuen sich meine
stimme ja morath und wenn so laut wie
schneide ich einfach raus dann kann ich
nämlich beim ton kann ich einfach der
pegel wieder runter setzen und dann ist
so als wäre ich wieder ganz allein und
als etwa keine kurven
ich mache jetzt heute was richtig
leckeres es gibt nämlich leckeren käse
sahne desserts mit mandarinen und mit
maracuja und das ist ein richtig tolles
das thema kannst gut vorbereiten auch
schon einen tag vorher
und ich finde es einfach so zuckersüß
aus diesem auf diesem teller und die
schmecken einfach auch total leicht und
ich werde jetzt einen schönen bizkit
machen
ich mache jetzt heute sechs portionen
habe aber zum beispiel gestern auch
schon zwölf portionen gemacht es geht
auch super aber ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten für sechs portionen erst mal
einfach nur den teig
ich habe hier zwei eier 100 gramm zucker
hier habe ich 40 g speisestärke und 50
gramm mehl 40 gramm butter die habe ich
bereits erlassen ist aber auch wieder
abgekühlt eineinhalb teelöffel
backpulver und 50 milliliter
mineralwasser ich habe eine zitrone dass
ich jetzt mit bio zitrone und davon
werde ich die schale benutzen und ich
habe wieder etwas beim anrather extrakt
ich habe mir jetzt hier mein backblech
vorbereitet mit meiner wie heißt murat
mit meinem bart rahmen und habe bis
jetzt so auf die größte einstellung eben
eingestellt und habe da meine dauer bak
wolle darunter und kann es jetzt einfach
nur so lassen und bereitet erstmal den
biskuit teig vor dafür gebe ich jetzt
die eier in die schüssel gemeinsam mit
dem zukauf irgendwie total komisch weil
ich weiß man halt in morath genauso gut
wie mich
da kommt jetzt wieder so
und das wird jetzt richtig lange
aufgeschlagen so etwa 345 minuten bis es
eben eine richtig schöne cremige masse
ist und business volumen eben oder
bittet richtig voluminöse
seht ihr die eier massa ist richtig
schön weiß geworden also weiß cremig und
so sieht sie dann eben aus also es ist
nicht so wie beim biskuitteig dass sie
eben jetzt fast steif ist so lange bis
jetzt nicht fühlen lassen
aber eben fast so dann nehme ich jetzt
mein wasser und gibt es mit dazu ist es
normales wasser oder mineralwasser mit
global ja warum ist cool dass ich es ins
mikrofon haben weil ich komme mir vor
wie als bis erstmalige drehen wie sommer
in seiner kochshow reist der einer der
kann einmal alles und andere wertstoffe
ich meine schauen und es hätte ganz
ruhig sein fragen warum das gemacht hat
warum ich es zum beispiel mineralwasser
ich hab das jetzt übrigens ganz kurz bei
niedriger stufe untergerührt ich nehme
hat immer gern mineralwasser weil ich
finde dass man da einfach den teig
lockerer hinbekommt ich nehme ich meine
trockenen zutaten und gibt die hier alle
zusammen rein ich hätte natürlich 7
damit keine klümpchen entstehen
jetzt nehme ich ein schneebesen und
rührt es einfach kurz ein so ganz locker
und kann es aber auch schon mal hier
die vanilleschote extrakt nehmen
da brauche ich nur ganz wenig wie bisher
warum ist dieses wollen eine schule
extrakt für weil die vanilleschote da
komplett drin steckt also das ist ja nur
vanille konzentrat drin in öl und da
schmeckt einfach viel besser den
vanillezucker ich habe auch immer
selbstgemachten weil diese zu katar hat
den ich auch gerne mal nehmen aber da
hat man einfach ein intensiveres aroma
und jetzt gebe ich noch die schale der
bio zitrone rein einfach damit so ein
bisschen fruchtiger schmeckt und zu die
diese zitronige note drin hat finde ich
im teig auch immer ganz schön so und
jetzt nehmen wir noch die zerlassene
butter
ihr könnt jetzt auch öl nehmen geht auch
gut ich nehme auch mal ganz gern butter
weil ich den geschmack der butter so mag
wird das alles einfach kurz untergerührt
gebe ich den teig in die vorbereitete
form
man könnte jetzt auch natürlich ein
schoko teig draus machen indem man
einfach etwas speisestärke und mailen
durch kakaopulver ersetzt aber das wird
jetzt mal richtig leckeren käse sahne
jetzt wird der teig hier einfach so ein
bisschen verteilt also gerade so ganz
leicht
und dann wird der teig gibt bei 200 grad
für etwa sieben bis acht minuten
gebacken
ich packte ihn jetzt bei 200 grad oder
sogar 210 ober und unterhitze damit
einfach schnell packt und nicht
austrocknet denn je niedriger ihr den
teig back gerade bei sehr dünnen zeigen
um so trockene werten sie und deswegen
eben nur sieben minuten bei 200 grad und
dann sehen wir uns in der teig wieder
kalt ist gut meint eigesetzt abgekühlt
und ich nehme jetzt einfach so einen
tortenring messer und entfernen damit
dem amt ich habe ihn ehrlich gesagt zwei
minuten zu lang drin gelassen aber ich
habe nach den sieben minuten noch mal
zwei minuten gemacht hätte ich einfach
toll
also lasst die last bei ungefähr sie
entfernen ja am ring mitte januar im
kostenrahmen ja rahmen des alltäglichen
sandra und man nimmt man so man nimmt er
sein messer weil ansonsten diese dauer
back folie beschädigt wird man kann auch
ein normales messer nehmen aber da muss
man sich oder neue folie kaufen und dann
nämlich zerschnitten wird jetzt habe ich
das ganze mitten im amt mit einer
anderen dauer bank vorliege stürzte
sieht man es wahrscheinlich nicht
schwarz auf schwarz
dann kann ich hier die folie nämlich
abziehen
und wie gesagt ich das jetzt die menge
für sechs portionen
falls sie jetzt aber sagt ich möchte
jetzt für zwölf personen was zubereiten
packt ihr diesen gleichen tag einfach
nochmal also nochmal so dünn und nicht
irgendwie zwei tage also 240 auf einmal
weil wir wollen ja keinen dicken teig
und ich werde das ganze jetzt schichten
und zwar habe ich da jetzt so kleine
gefäße dafür ich hab die auch in rund
die hatte ich euch irgendwann mal vor
einem jahr über einem jahr schon gezeigt
und zwar sind die es von tupperware ich
habe zwar auch torten ringe oder so dass
er ringe zeige ich euch mal kurz gibt ja
auch so dass er dinge die man immer
super nehmen kann
allerdings mag ich bei diesem deshalb
diese mehr weil einfach da die stapelbar
sind das heißt ich habe einfach im
kühlschrank wenig platz verbraucht und
diamanten deckel und ich kann sie halt
super gut transportieren und deswegen
nehme ich ganz gern tief von tupperware
und jetzt habe ich hier noch so ein
austritt mit dabei und damit kann ich
jetzt den teig ausstechen brauche ich
jetzt natürlich für die sechsfache menge
brauche ich jetzt zwölf stück weil ich
nämlich einmal am boden und einmal einen
deckel habe das ganze aus plastik
deswegen macht es jetzt auch nix hier
ich habe ja die folie darunter
kunststoffe ich der richtige ausdruck
plastik ist allgemein ist ja kunststoff
ich bin jedoch korrekt zu bleiben
ich finde es erstaunlich dass de moura
dessen mikrofon hat na ja ich sag mal
nichts das so
und jetzt nämlich schon mal den boden
und setzte ihn hier rein also immer eins
pro form
und jetzt lasse ich das hier einfach
kurz stehen und kümmere mich um die
füllung und für die füllung habe ich mir
hier schon die zutaten hingerichtet und
zwar traurig 150 milliliter kalte
schlagsahne
dann habe ich hier zwei teelöffel ist
dann abfahrt und zwar benutze ich das
gerne zum sahne steifen und damit die
krähen ebenfalls bleibt hier habe ich
200 gramm magerquark zwei esslöffel
butter zucker jedoch die zitrone von
durch die schale abgerieben hatte da
brauche ich jetzt die hälfte davon also
den saft noch mal mein vanille
konzentrate was bald zu ende ist
deswegen stets auf dem kopf und ich hab
hier mandarinen aus der dose
die muss ich jetzt noch abgießen und
macht es einfach in so einem fall kann
man ganz normale sieg sein und dies die
einfach kurz ab ihr könnt jetzt die
flüssigkeit auffangen und zb auch ein
teil von der flüssigkeit dann gleich
noch mit so grün geben
und jetzt habe ich liebe sally oliver
morath warum ist sie keine frischen
mandarin weil du bist doch erst ein typ
der immer frische sachen und jetzt
nimmst du comedians administration die
arbeiten mandarin ist ganz einfach
die haben ja alle so eine schöne haut
auf ihm rum und es war viel zu
anstrengend die dünne haut ausnahme zu
entfernen
die filets herauszuschneiden wobei ich
mich jetzt beim aussprechen sogar gerade
frage wie wandert die mandarine aus
ihrer schale in die dose starb sogar
richtig interessant da mal das
rauszufinden ob die das dann mit seiner
beute machen dass die haut praktisch so
verschwindet oder wird es da einfach
raus kommt das wäre ein fall für ihn
willy das war schon interessant
murat wird wissen moratti oft
entdeckungstour ich werde
marien fahren gehen oder irgendwie
wieder los werden uns anschauen
ganz genau zu machen wir das während
sich noch gedanken über seine exkursion
macht werde ich schon mal die sahne
steif schlagen und zwar rühre ich die
ganz kurz mal an und auch nicht für
höchster stufe zeiten bei sahne kann man
ruhig das langsame rühren damit mehr
luft rein kommt und dann gebe ich jetzt
für steinert gleichen dazu ihr könnt
auch weglassen
aber dann besteht eventuell die gefahr
dass viel sahne eben nie zu lange
standhält
aber dreht täglich auch ohne unser ball
die sahne steif ist kann ich sie kurz
weg stellen und mich um den quark
kümmern
den gebe ich jetzt einfach in eine
andere schüssel rein der muss nämlich
auch kurz verrührt werden
da gebe ich jetzt wie gesagt so ein
bisschen vom mandarinen saft dazu gerade
so 1 2 esslöffel aber eigentlich ist ja
kein saft sicher mehr zuckerwasser
deswegen lieber bis sparsam dann etwas
von der vanilleschote den puderzucker
gebe ich rein aber den sie bereits
vorher damit einfach keine klümpchen
gibt
dann den saft der zitrone also wie
gesagt nämlich darf man nur die hälfte
wir können jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
zitronenschale mit rein geben aber ich
denke das ist so schon genug
und jetzt wird es kurz verrührt jetzt
schalte ich natürlich auf niedriger
stufe
die creme übrigens ein bisschen durch
den ganzen stonesoft etwas zu flüssig
deswegen gebe ich da jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen salat mit rein
ich fühle mir das übrigens immer in so
ein kleines döschen ab einfach so ein
teelöffel ungefähr 1 bis 2 was haben und
jetzt wird die sahne unter dem quad
gehoben ganz locker ganz leicht jetzt
könnt ihr an der stelle gern auch
schmecken wenn ihr möchtet falls euch
zum beispiel zu wenig zitrone drin ist
oder zu viel zucker mit dazu geben
aber für mich ist hier so perfekt und
ich werde es jetzt in einen spritzbeutel
füllen damit ich das gleich besser da
rein spritzen kann
dafür nehme ich einfach so einen großen
dokter und gebt da vorne so eine große
loch thüle dran
ihr könnt zum beispiel aber auch in
einwegspritzen ohne schüler nehmen
aber in dem fall arbeitet jetzt mit mit
tulip lieber 8 bringt mich ganz
durcheinander weil ein paar dann
stabiler ist und das fühle ich jetzt
hier rein
dann lasse ich den spritzbeutel einfach
mal kurz stehen und für mich ganz kurz
um die mandarinen den da mach ich jetzt
dass ich mir die in die form reinlegen
also ich nehme es immer die mandarine
und legt sie hier an den rand dass ich
praktisch rundherum wenig später den
tortenring entferne
die mandarin daneben zu sehen und jetzt
nämlich die sahne creme und spritzt es
einfach innen rein also zuerst in die
mitte und nach oben hin witz und einfach
bisschen mehr und damit der rand auch
richtig schön wird und nicht zum
verlängert wird nehme ich mir einfach so
eine kleine palette und kann mit dieser
kleinen mini palette des noch so ein
bisserl verstreichen bis zum rand und da
müsste einfach darauf achten dass es so
richtig sauber wird das ist nämlich
wichtig weil das dann später umso
schöner aussieht und jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach die tankdeckel und legt die hier
oben drauf drückt sie leicht an
da gab es auch noch so eindrücke mit
dabei also kann ich die schön flach
drücken
dann setze ich da das zweite drauf ich
kann dir stapeln und mache jetzt einfach
so weiter ich lege jetzt immer so drei
stück übereinander
dann kommt der deckel drauf und so
dürfen die dann in den kühlschrank für
etwa eine stunde aber ihr könnt es zum
beispiel auch eine nacht vorher machen
die anderen zwei mache ich gleich noch
fertig aber ich wollte euch noch zeigen
was ihr auch machen könnt falls ihr zum
beispiel sagt ich mich auch so ein
kleines dessert machen habe aber diese
formen nicht ihr könnt auch einfach ein
glas nehmen und damit zum beispiel den
teig ausstechen oder auch mit einem
ausstecher oder ist vor der reform des
aus stellten jetzt nicht mehr so viel
zeit übrig aber das macht nichts ich
habe jetzt hier ein fast rundes und hier
noch ein rundes rausbekommen und gebe
jetzt einfach dieses fast runde unten
ins glas wright bisschen sahne rein dann
ein paar mandarinen die könnte er auch
jetzt hier richtig schön am rand entlang
einsetzen
dann einfach nochmal creme
und den deckel
ja man kann auch weitermachen also je
nachdem ob man jetzt viel drin haben
möchte oder wenig wenn man jetzt noch
eine schicht haben wollte wollt könnt
ihr jetzt noch eine rein machen aber ich
finde dann ist zu viel also das zu viel
des er
und so fuhr ich sehr von der funktion
her genauso groß wie das kleine dass er
und es stelle ich jetzt einfach auch
kurz kühl und zeigt euch dann gleich wie
ich das so wäre jetzt sind meine dass es
kalt und ich möchte jetzt servieren aber
ich möchte nicht einfach jetzt den
kuchen auf dem teller geben sondern ich
möchte noch einen richtig leckeren
fruchtigen frucht spiegel dazu machen
und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht was passt
jetzt gut zu käse sahne und zu den
mandarinen
deswegen habe ich gedacht nämlich
einfach maracuja und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier einfach ein paar maracuja ich denke
die mehrzahl schmack rias und zwar sieht
man hier also die die außen und die
heißt dass alle aussehen ja die
nesensohn aber das ist so aus wie beim
zielgenau sie den sänger im gesicht hat
so sagt man auf jeden fall müssen die so
aussehen dann sind sie nämlich richtig
schön süß aber ihr könnt auch gern
teilnehmen aber wie gesagt bevorzugt
einfach die rauen dann habe ich falls
ihr die zum beispiel nicht hab das jetzt
einfach so das i-tüpfelchen natürlich
die gibt's auch nicht überall also ich
habe jetzt bei uns im globus gekauft da
ist nämlich so eine exotische abteilung
wo es einfach drachenfrucht gibt da gibt
es alles da gibt es einfach alles und da
gibt es die mit dabei aber wenn ihr
sowas nicht in der nähe habt nehmt
einfach in maracujasaft den nehme ich
jetzt nämlich auch und etwas
speisestärke ich würde mal sagen ich
nehme einfach so etwa ein halbes glas
voll saft und gibt es in den topf
ungefähr 100 milliliter
es kommt einfach jetzt darauf an wie
viel frucht spielte ihr das machen
wollte da gebe ich jetzt etwa ein
teelöffel speisestärke dazu
das eben damit gebunden wird und
verrührte sitzt schön und jetzt schalte
ich den herd ein und lasse ich einfach
kurz aufkochen
das dürfte jetzt eine halbe minute
minute lang kochen und ich lasse es
jetzt ganz kurz ein bisschen abkühlen
dann wird auch etwas fester denn ich
möchte es ja nicht heißen wir unseren
kalt und in der zeit zeige ich euch
jetzt schon mal die maracuja und zwar
muss man jetzt einfach mal halbieren
innen ist sie holen und da steckt dann
auch diese frucht drin also dass hier
des innen drin das kama essen das gelbe
die schale aber nicht essen
es müsste einfach einen löffel nähe hat
mit seinem freund gegeben den tipp und
das ganze hier drin so wie sie klebrig
rühren dann löst sich das nämlich auch
besser und jetzt gebe ich diese masse
einfach mit hier in den frucht spiegel
damit rein
das riecht einfach richtig lecker und
ich habe maracuja auch neulich zum
ersten mal gegessen also ich kannte es
maracujasaft und geschmack den geschmack
kantig aber ich bin da musst du echt mal
einfach so essen vor allem die kerne
wenn man darauf weist das ist ein ganz
anderer gemacht wie dieser kaugummi das
wurde drauf der zuhörer stadtplatz der
immer so genau das ist so ähnlich
richtig genial für ein kaufmann hat das
ist dann so richtig kleber oder nicht
richtig toll
die teuersten zu machen
also der kost eine maracuja habe ich
jetzt gezahlt 129 eur 29 schon heftig
eine frucht guck mal das sieht jetzt
vielleicht für euch bisserl
unappetitlich aus der dinge aus wie so
kleine augen morath aber ich sage euch
das ist sehr lecker
ich lasse jetzt kurz abkühlen und mein
mann darf mir mal kurz meine dass es aus
dem kühlschrank holen
und jetzt kann ich mir das servier ich
habe jetzt einfach mal drei täler weil
man heute gleich zu dritt sind diese
nicht richtig schön kalt und jetzt geht
es ganz einfach so ich nehme das jetzt
und klingt mit dass auf dem teller und
da oben das ist auch richtig cool
gemacht
drücke ich das einfach runter so
praktisch da meint jetzt her
jetzt könnt euch überlegen will ich die
mandarinen oben oder unten das heißt ich
könnte noch ein teller drauflegen und
das ganze stürzen
und da gebe ich jetzt noch bissl
puderzucker drauf aber ich nehme da
jetzt keinen normalen weil wenn ich
selbst in normalen fordert sogar drauf
gibt dann schmilzt dann mit der zeit
oben drauf deswegen nehme ich jetzt den
süßen schnee der schmidt ist nämlich
nicht auch wenn er feucht wird dass ich
halt dieser puderzucker der zum beispiel
auch auf berlinern drauf ist wo kriegt
man diesen süßen schnee her wenn ihr im
shop der uns sonst war ich glaube nicht
nehmen weil es schon extra puderzucker
für becker eben und jetzt setze ich das
aber ganz kurz noch mal um weil ich
jetzt nicht möchte das jetzt hier
überall foto zucker ist
jetzt habe ich hier zum beispiel so ein
löffel und deko riffel der hat er unten
so eine öffnung und mit dem kann ich
jetzt hier geht auch mit normaler löffel
kann ich jetzt hier einfach diese soße
am rand sind dekorativ anrichten
dann können dass zum beispiel noch so
ein paar mandarinen mit reinlegen dem
ich mir jetzt wollen weg gelegt und dann
doch so einem ins blättchen und dann
habt ihr so eigentlich ganz schnell so
ein dessertteller gezaubert mit relativ
wenig aufwand wie machst du im glas beim
glas das kann stimmen und ich denke hier
noch ein paar teller und im glas würde
ich einfach so anrichten ich nehme
einfach wieder mein schnee zucker und
gibt also schnee drauf frau holle die
frau holle
aber ich finde noch höher machen können
durch noch zwei schichten machen könnt
ja das ist das schöne außerdem
vielleicht ein dünneres class aber so
wenn ich jetzt dann noch eine schicht
darauf habe ich einfach zu viel
also ich finds und desserts sollte wenig
zeit und gut schmecken
dann gebe ich den frucht spiegel einfach
so drauf am besten so als klicks können
wir jetzt auch in einem glas ganz gut
einfach innen rein geben schon und dann
hier einfach so zwei mann bringen sind
drauf
gute sieht man gut läuft gerade das
wasser im mund zusammen doch richtig
hübsch gut murat die stunde der wahrheit
ja und deinen teller war ein schnapsglas
gebe ich bin da relativ den kaputten
teller gibt letztlich auch die kerne
darauf weisen auf die maracuja gerne
ganz wichtig mit richtig cool um diese
kerne wahnsinn sally das ist ein richtig
gutes des herodot ihr dürft mir gerne
wenn ihr das gemacht habt ein bild auf
facebook oder instagram schicken da
freue ich mich sehr darüber und ihr
dürft mir auch gerne ein paar ideen
geben falls ihr zum beispiel gerne noch
andere glas desserts oder so einfach
dass es haben möchtet könnt ihr mir
gerne schreiben und dieses rezept gibt
es wie alle anderen rezepte auf sally -
blog.de
ich freue mich schon aufs nächste mal
wie de macht es nach stefan sind
muratow darf
zeit ruhig ich möchte nur die auf die
nerven gehen sind sagt echt nicht
übertreiben leid darf ich noch atmen
darf aber nur leise du musst mikrofon
weiter runde machen statt sich sein